there's obviously a booby trap that has
been installed in many of our minds
where
because of the what I now regard as the
Absurd portrayal of anti-vaxxers as a
simple
monolithic phenomenon many of us have
difficulty
wrapping our minds around the
possibility that something that we've
been told as a vaccine could possibly be
doing massive levels of harm which is
absurd because obviously many vaccines
uh have not gotten past trials on the
basis that safety signals emerged others
have been pulled from the market after
Adverse Events
uh signals showed that they were unsafe
so they're not inherently Safe products
um and I think it took many of us some
time to get past the idea that
effectively
anti-vaxxers Were Free Riders who were
getting the benefit of other people's
taking a small risk and being vaccinated
they were getting the benefit of those
people's immunity which in fact is I'm
certain a part of the phenomenon but
others had legitimate concerns
which frankly aren't easily dismissed in
one Fell Swoop
yes completely I think what's
interesting is people have asked me why
did you you know you've been a big
critic and skeptic of drug industry why
did you take the vaccine at the
beginning and of course it was
complicated reasons for me personally
both on a personal level but also on the
fact that I I can you know I'm not a
vaccine expert and I didn't even predict
or expect this would happen
um but uh I think that
um
you know
what I would say certainly is that many
people at the beginning Brett
I would say didn't take the vaccine for
irrational reasons
and the people who are now deciding they
don't want boosters or whatever else so
many of them are not taking it for
rational reasons because some of those
original thoughts around the vaccine
okay we don't know the long-term effects
but then we don't know the long-term
effects of many things right at the
beginning we didn't really have very
strong data at the very beginning on the
harm certainly not high quality data
so a lot of that was maybe intuition it
could be
um people uh were buying into
things that really are quite ridiculous
I think such as it's part of a
depopulation agenda there are microchips
in the vaccine many of the people who
didn't take it were taking it you know
not taking it for those reasons so
um I I don't think certainly for me as a
cardiologist although I could have been
more skeptical and taken longer to make
a personal decision on it I wouldn't
have been able to have the data that I
was able to produce in that paper a
couple of months ago I didn't have that
data at my disposal at the very
beginning to to make a very clear
decision that this vaccine is going to
cause significant harm and doesn't have
much benefit we didn't it took time for
us to gather that information
it did although you know I came at this
from a different route I knew full well
that there was a problem with Pharma I
knew that if I opened because of the
experience with with mouse telomeres I
know that when I opened my medicine
cabinet I see a a bunch of question
marks and even as somebody who's well
informed about the issue I'm in no
position to say which of those question
marks are
um filled in with a hazard I can't see
and which of those you know pills might
be safe
so you know I was on alert but I think
the larger you know there's a question
about what you call
irrational
now the microchip
uh allegation is irrational it's
counter-rational I believe
um on the other hand
I don't feel that way about somebody who
decided not to take it on the basis that
they are aware that our system is
corrupt and therefore what they're being
told about safety May well not be true
that is it's kind of meta-rationality
that's rational no that's rational
yeah vaccine hesitancy absolutely yeah
so okay good I'm glad we're we're
aligned actually interestingly when I
went on Good Morning Britain I actually
addressed it I said there were rational
and irrational concerns about the
vaccine I said the rational concerns are
exactly what you said Brett uh because
let's look at the history of Pharma you
know their business model is fraud and
this is what they've done you know they
they are we've got an issue of the third
most common cause of death after heart
disease and cancer
um I'll prescribed medications and that
is rooted in Pharma corruption so I said
that's completely rational absolutely
yeah it is irrational I will say it's an
interesting pattern that I've noticed
among the coveted dissidents you
included uh is how many of the coveted
dissidents are in fact uh inoculated
with these vaccines for covet 19.
um so even people who were well
positioned to see it
uh the the ramping up of the campaign
was so rapid and the messaging was so
black and white that I think even people
who were primed to be able to detect it
got caught off guard yeah and I think
that for me was when when things turned
for me is when they suddenly when I
started looking obviously the potential
homes but when they turned it into
mandate and I say ramping up the
campaign then I knew that there was a
problem I knew there was an issue and
certainly I knew then it was more about
profit than protecting people right and
that's when you know I campaigned and I
did help to some degree I was a very
prominent campaigner to get the vaccine
mandate overturned for National Health
Service staff I spent months you know
both in mainstream media and behind the
scenes making that happen so
um I knew that that was taking things
way too far absolutely and then and then
the final point I think um as well
um Brett is I find it very difficult to
believe
the Pfizer scientists didn't know by the
end of their randomized control trial
before the drug was approved
that this was going to cause significant
harm to many people and I wonder is that
why they were so strong in getting
indemnification from governments against
um you know being liable if uh if there
were you know vaccine injuries
which means if that is correct Brett
it should never have been approved in
the first place should never have been
approved and you know one piece of
evidence uh that is suggestive you're
right about this is that the discovery
after they were released about how much
harm they do hasn't changed things a bit
from the perspective of you know Pharma
has not become cautious over them so
there's no reason to think that they
learned about those harms late since it
didn't change their trajectory at all
yeah well well a psychopathic entity
won't change right they have to be
forced to be they have to be forced into
into a position where
um you know they are made accountable
it's quite right
um uh two final things from my side
you're welcome to enter anything in the
discussion that you want to
um are you concerned for yourself having
gotten a double dose of the Pfizer
vaccine
great question
um
I think that
I'm an optimist I think that certainly
from what we've seen most of the serious
Adverse Events tend to happen early on
of course with the exception maybe of
cardioactive disease progressing Etc and
people already have underlying coronary
artery disease
um
I am
I think there's wishful thinking I'm
hopeful that I'm probably okay and I
think most people should also feel that
way but the honest answer Brett is we
don't know but what what good is that
going to do I think psychologically
worrying about something that hasn't
happened
um isn't of any benefit right now in the
same way that we don't worry we
shouldn't we're all gonna die
so why worry about death you know
um when it when it's not something
that's imminent why worry about it well
I am a a fan it's my own invention so
maybe I'm not a fan but I am uh
personally I advocate for what I call
adaptive dwelling which is to say you
should dwell on something exactly to the
point that dwelling on it further
doesn't do you any good at which point
you should abandon it and what I would
say is there's one way in which I think
a little bit of dwelling is probably
valuable and believe me I don't want
people worried about something that's in
the past and can't be undone what I do
want people to understand which I
suspect is not it's not well known in
public
is that this is not the place for a well
I'm already vaccinated what can I do
style of analysis the point is they're
continuing to push boosters on people
and new versions and everything I
understand about this suggests that the
risk through one of a couple different
mechanisms and maybe they're both in
play
the risk is likely to be cumulative
we've seen that to some extent in the
data but at the very least maybe you got
away with it if you got away with it
keep yourself as safe from this stuff as
you can absolutely yeah no more and I
think also obviously my duty and
responsibility as an advocate and a
doctor is to make sure no further harm
happens to anybody else and that's why I
was so strong on this because people
would say to you know see people say
well hold on your dad died what can you
do you can't bring him back I said hold
on my responsibility is to make sure
that doesn't happen to anybody else I
think the other thing as well that
people can think about Brett is it it
does appear certainly that certainly
with covet and even maybe with the
vaccine the people who are most
vulnerable to side effects are people
who are already in poor metabolic health
so they have conditions relation related
to excess body fat so one of the things
that people can do certainly is just get
themselves in better shape because if
these effects are pro-inflammatory and
related to conditions like heart disease
your best counter is to Institute
lifestyle changes that are going to
mitigate or minimize those risks and I
think that's something that people can
proactively do that's something I I
follow my own advice
um and certainly some of my patients
with long covid have got significantly
better once they've lost weight they've
improved their diet and their symptoms
have improved so I think we should all
focus on making sure our Baseline has
health is as best as possible as it can
be and maybe one of the downstream or
maybe one of the effects of all of this
so I mean something I highlighted very
um I was very vocal on at the beginning
of the pandemic um you know highlighting
the link between obesity and adverse
Health outcomes is that we moving
forward actually if we're going to make
the population more resilient for the
next pandemic God forbid it happened it
happens anytime soon is to make our
um you know our metabolic Health as best
as possible through you know dietary
changes getting good sleep going back to
the basics keeping stress levels low
meditation I'm sure these are all things
that you are a strong proponent of of
course and that's what I would say
people can do and be proactive about
yep I would also say you know this was a
very painful way to learn certain things
uh in the book I mentioned before
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century
um not only did Heather and I say that
we thought vaccines were one of the
three great medical interventions in all
of history which I still believe though
now with a caveat
um but we also took a strong position uh
against the likely utility of
supplementation
um
on the basis that by and large a good
diet ought to provide you what you need
which is something I now do not believe
I know better in fact in at least one
case where most of us are chronically
deficient in vitamin D because diet is
not the mechanism through which you
procure it and our lifestyles block us
from the contact with the Sun that would
produce normal amounts of it our
clothing the windows that Shield UV the
fact that we live indoors all of these
things cause us to be chronically
deficient especially if we live at high
or low latitudes and so in any case I'm
coming to understand that a that my
model was too simple also a good diet
means you don't need to supplement and
there's no benefit you know the only
reason you need to supplement is if
you're deficient that part is true but a
lot of us are deficient and maybe in
more than one thing because our highly
novel Lifestyles block the normal way in
which we'd accrue these things
yeah 100 and vitamin D has so many
important roles in the body as a
pro-hormone
um not just in bone health as you
mentioned in the immune system
um but even in heart health you know the
vitamin D deficiency is associated with
a six-fold increased risk of developing
coronation disease so
um yeah I'm with you 100 and if you can
ideally get it obviously get it from
getting some good sun exposure but if
not then certainly through winter months
or if you're in a place where you don't
get much sun exposure then yeah
supplements are definitely the way
forward I'm 100 uh an advocate of
vitamin D yeah yeah well uh I'm also an
advocate of leveraging Technology
there's an app there may be more than
one but I use one called D minder which
tells you actually during what hours of
the day you are capable of making
vitamin D from sun exposure you know
simply being in the sun doesn't do it
and the angle of the sun you'd be
surprised I'm now in a phase as I would
imagine you are you're you're in Britain
um in which it's impossible to make
vitamin D no matter how much light
you're exposed to and just simply having
a you know a a calculation that tells
you okay I did pretty good over the
summer making vitamin D but I should be
supplementing because I can't be making
it until I think sometime in late
February
that's an important an important piece
of information to have
[Music]